can you tell me the story of your
childhood
it's definitely outside the scope of the
norm well today maybe not 150 or 200
years ago
but
uh my parents
highly intelligent you know people
coming out of the bay area
my mom was
you know going to school to be a
chemical engineer she was a top top
student athlete graduated at her school
my father was a member of mensah
my stepfather was just a genius but not
able to really function in society but
my mom was you know she had some demons
and some other stuff and just
she just said one day she's like i just
don't want to be part of society
she still isn't
lives out in the desert but uh has her
minds but
she
wanted to figure out a way to make a
life outside of that and so that's where
we ended up is
up in the mountains in northern
california and
a lot of that was you know them trying
to
get into
successfully growing marijuana which
back in that you know wasn't legal back
then highly illegal and in fact those
areas were some of the areas we lived
were quite dangerous so there's a
documentary
murder mountain that came out recently
if you watch that you'll tie into my
book
just the understanding of the stuff that
i was talking about dealing with
serial killers
human trafficking police corruption
uh murderers
like
just how real that stuff is if it
doesn't capture you from the book okay
the book by the way is the eagle and the
dragon yeah thank you
yeah i'm a terrible sales person like i
told you
so
but a good uh it's a good title i don't
know if you came up with it but uh i did
yeah so yeah we'll talk about that
anyway we're living by a stream you know
alpha meadow there's no roads into where
you have to hike in
and we've got beams lashed into the
trees up above us because that's where
our bedding is because there's
rattlesnake dens all around and six
years old
i'm being taught how to capture and
handle live rattlesnakes because that's
what i need to do to be safe
and you can imagine six years old
sitting there with a live rattlesnake in
your hand grabbing it you know by the
side of the head controlling so it can't
can't bite you and it's just wrapping
itself around your arm and you're
staring at like it's only intent is
right then is to kill you
like that's it right
um
you want to take a bath it's filling up
the jug in the stream and setting it out
on the rockster and uh during the sun so
you dump it over your head and you know
not all the living was that way you know
good part was similar to that tent
living
living in a 16-foot trailer with a
family of six which is
not much bigger than the space that
we're sitting here
so we're talking hard winters with feet
of snow on the ground nowhere to go
i'm living in the back of the the pickup
truck in a
just a standard sleeping bag that we get
from the salvation army not the not the
blow zero so i'm uh i'm i'm not sleeping
well there's living in homes that were
maybe uh condemned there's no no doors
even on them
no electricity or running water or one
or the other or both and sometimes a
little bit better by the time we got to
high school
we had a mobile home
so my stepfather had won a disability
payment because he had a broken arm that
whole time
from an accident a long time ago and
finally got an award and got a down
payment on this mobile home that
didn't have again doors on the inside it
did have running water did have
electricity didn't have a kitchen
you know the windows would crank close
and open but they wouldn't close all the
way so the
trim them in with plastic to be able to
try to protect from the elements
that was my environment like learning
how to forage for mushrooms i mean
there's summers i would send and my
parents would be out they were in the
drug trade earlier we got taken by the
by the police and put into
foster care for for a while which
ties into some of the stories with human
trafficking and honestly it's in my book
but it's really hard for me to
talk about that
stuff um and obviously not all that's in
the book so
um but they got us back we moved to
oregon and they stayed out of the drug
trade from that time to ensure that
they didn't lose us again but quickly we
kind of fell back into the same thing so
at that point it was
learning about geology and starting to
do mining
and
firewood cutting but mostly the mining
because pat's broken arm chainsaw made a
little tough
if you remember just the sequence of
moments
do you um are you haunted by the the
darker moments of your childhood do you
remember
moments of simple joy and happiness
outside of the
living around dangerous people and the
interactions that came from that
we were a family like we were a cohesive
unit battling against the world together
we spent
all our time together
work play
i was there i was helping raise my my
siblings where i was working with them
and
you know it was a constant like i said
we were very physically active so you
know i had that in my upbringing um plug
for my shoe company barefoot b-e-a-r
i ran around the wilderness and bare
feet all the time you know but it was
i had a lot of great
moments and i'm thankful for a lot of
that childhood once we take out the
trauma and the other stuff associated
with it right
and so
the connection that i have with my
sisters
um is is is huge
um that goes a bit further to because i
am kind of like a little bit of a father
figure because i was home raising them
and then later i took custody of them
while i was going to school because the
environment at home deteriorated further
their
stepfather like i said was
he wasn't capable of managing life and
my mom had a mental breakdown and took
off to montana and he descended into
madness even worse
actually took my 13 year old sister and
kicked her out in the middle of winter a
couple feet of snow on the ground
because he thought she stole his
favorite cereal bowl
um type so that's when i took in and i
was going to college putting myself
through college and i started taking
custody of my sisters and raising them
so anyway we're still like very
very tight family um it took there was a
few years later
in life like
that the connection with my mother was
kind of broken
um i didn't speak to her for years
because of her basically abandoning my
sisters and me having to come in but
that we've worked through that as best
we can so you anger on your part it
wasn't
there might have been some anger um did
you always love her yes and i still do
and i'm so she's taught me
basically everything i know about
strength and perseverance and
living life on your terms
and being able to to create that and so
much of what i am
is from that right
we've all had to learn to
be okay with the way she is because she
is just
blunt but you know she's the one that
figured out that the human trafficking
situation and got
got the d.a involved and got all the
she's the one that
i've learned a lot from her
you